if all of the learnings that were taught
to me were only through auditory I would
feel like a stupid human being it is one
of the most powerful exercises that I
think you can ever do in your life you
love the work you love the process you
love the how not just the why what's up
elimination it seven I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so to
help you on your journey today we're
gonna look at seven steps you can follow
to figure out how you are unique also if
you want to know what I and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
surround yourself with greatness
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through success in
business and life ultimately comes down
to you understanding how unique you are
and bringing that to every aspect of
your business and your life I'm a big
fan of violin success I'm a big fan of
learning from other people that can help
you get so far but if all you are is a
photocopy of somebody else you will
never have ultimate success and so the
point of today's video is to give you
seven different strategies on how you
can find how you are unique and then
bring that to your business
[Music]
step number one is do the one-word
exercise your one word is your single
most important core value when you
figure out what that is it's the it's
the base layer it's the ground level for
everything that you do in your life it
comes down to human core values and I
believe you have one core value that is
above all aus and when you figure that
out it is one of the most powerful
exercises that I think you can ever do
in your life and so my one word is
believe when I discovered that my entire
path started to make sense and it gave
me a clearer picture of where I should
be going when I brought that to my
business everything started to blow up
when I brought that to my youtube
channel everything started to blow up
and we've seen that pattern repeat
itself for others consistently with time
over and over and over again so you need
to figure out what your one-word most
important core value is okay step two is
figure out your credo your credo is the
three-part breakdown of your one worth
you got your one word on top the top of
the pyramid the credo is a three-part
definition of what that means because
there's often going to be a standard
definition of what it means to the
general public to the people around you
and you will need them to help you build
your mission but then there's more
details more specificity for you of what
it looks like in your world so believed
as an example for me believe breaks down
into passion self confidence and impact
self confidence the one that makes the
most sense like believe in yourself how
self confidence believe in it believe
that you are amazing right that is
absolutely true but it's only a piece of
my one word for me passion is the next
one believe in the work that you're
doing believe in the work believe in the
process believe in the passion for the
work I love making videos I love helping
entrepreneurs I believe in what I'm
doing not just the result that I'm after
and the third part is believing the
impact that it will have believing the
conviction follow through and so those
three things help make up belief for me
and gives me clarity over every decision
that I make going forward another quick
example freedom is the one word of one
of my guys on my film crew named brahim
and freedom for him break down into
three things honesty hard work and
experiences now that may make sense to
you it may not make sense to you it
doesn't matter that's what freedom looks
like the him
honesty hard work and experiences now he
knows how to direct his life he knows
how to deal with people he knows that
people that he wants in his life he
knows the kind of projects that he wants
to work on freedom and then honesty hard
work and gaining experiences I have a
girl on my team named Christie who is
training to be an instructor TDS her one
word is freedom as well but it breaks
down totally differently and that's the
beauty of it you figure out your one
word and then you figure the Credo of
what that one word means to you to give
you absolute clarity over what you
should be working on number three is
find your purpose it's great to have an
understanding of what your core values
are and how that breaks down what now
you need to figure out is how you're
going to apply it so it's great that I
believe but I could believe in lots of
different things and lots of different
people why do I love helping
entrepreneurs is step three it's knowing
your purpose your purpose comes from
your pain understanding the suffering
and pain that you have been through is
your path to then go out and help other
people the reason why I love helping
entrepreneurs and that's my purpose is
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur when you have been through
something massively painful and
traumatic its natural it's human nature
that you want to give back and you want
to help people who are currently
suffering and struggling with that thing
and so instead of trying to forget the
past instead of trying to block out the
negativity and all the pain that you
went through understand that that is
your purpose that having gone through
that allows you to help other people who
are currently going through the same
thing and so find your purpose and your
purpose comes from your pain
[Music]
set number fours understand who you
serve I think people fall in the two
buckets here either you want to serve
the world you have a big mission you
want to help as many people as possible
or you want to serve the people closest
to you to the 10 20 people who are
closest to your close friends your close
family so as an example you guys asked
me and Nina if I had a choice between a
hundred thousand people hearing my
message and my son Hayden hearing my
message
I picked a hundred thousand people over
Hayden and my wife Nina picked Hayden
over two hundred thousand people I would
probably pick millions of people over
over my children I care more about math
I care more about the bigger impact I
think I'll pick my children Yeah right
so our minds are skewed a little bit
right we're on different ends of the
spectrum I want to help the world now
what I pick Hayden over ten people
probably where is the number where does
the number go don't ask you that
question it's a difficult road to travel
but a hundred thousand people I'm
picking a hundred thousand people over
my own son to hear my message right it
sounds crazy but that's how I'm wired I
want to help the world I want to help
the masses where Nina wants to help the
people closest to her and so
understanding of how you're wired
there's nothing wrong with one or the
other but understanding how you're wired
will help you understand how your unique
and then how you can bring those gifts
out to the people that you want to serve
[Music]
step number five is understanding how
you can serve there's a lot of different
things that you can do to help people
the people that you want to target
through your one word but you might not
like all of those activities and so an
example I gave Nina when we're going
through this exercise was her one word
is care she loves helping people out she
loves helping the people closest to her
but the ways that she care can be
expressed in many different ways so for
example helping somebody move right she
might do that because she really cares
about them but she doesn't like the
process of helping the move we're
organizing events she will do for people
she does it for me because she cares
about me he wants to see me win but she
also enjoys the process and that's when
you start to win when you understand
what is the process that you enjoy doing
is when you will start to win on a big
scale because you're not doing it just
to help out you're not doing just to
fulfill your mission but you hate the
work you love the work you love the
process you love the how not just the
why I love making videos I love meeting
with entrepreneurs one-on-one I love
doing it and so that's why I keep doing
it make a list of all the things that
you have done to help people and then
look at that list and see which ones
that you actually enjoy the process of
doing not just the result of giving back
[Music]
step number six understanding how you
are unique is figure out your learning
style you got visual you got auditory
you got kinesthetic for me I'm a visual
learner I love learning through video
for me the hardest way that I learn is
through auditory it's really hard if you
are just speaking to me and I can't see
things so for example I love consuming
video I've created a brand around this
video I make this video southla she for
myself because I want this content to
exist because I've created my own
university for myself to learn from and
I share that freely with all that you
guys as well it's selfish this is how I
learn is it's what I want to see in the
world I'm being the change that I want
to see podcast
I don't consume at all the only podcast
I've listened to are the ones that I've
been on that episode I've never I've
never consumed any other pot
Cass because I just don't learn that
it's really hard if I force myself to do
it I could do it
but it's definitely not my preferred
learning style and so because there's so
many other options I default to not
learning that way when my team is
talking to me and they're sharing
something I much rather have them sit
face to face or show me instead of
reading off of a Word document that I'm
trying to listen from their words and so
understanding your learning style helps
propel yourself forward if you know that
you learn through visuals and design
your life in your environment where you
can learn through visuals because if you
are in a situation where you're only
learning through auditory you're gonna
feel stupid I would feel stupid if all
of the learnings that were taught to me
were only through auditory I would feel
like a stupid human being I feel really
slow I wouldn't understand why I'm not
getting this stuff and it's only because
I'm a visual learner and so when you
figure out the style that fits for you
then you can start designing your
learning path so that you can win and
step number seven is take the sixteen
personality test this is a test you can
go to for free it's 16 personalities
calm
I'm not associated with the company
apart from being a fan of their service
and a customer I bought the deeper
understanding of each personality types
of myself it's great because it helps
you understand a little bit more about
yourself
I am the advocate personality and the
advocate let me see what it say advocate
I am quiet and mystical yet very
inspiring and tireless idealist that's
the overview but it tells you how to
deal with people and work it tells you
the kinds of jobs you should be in and
tells you the kind of relationships that
you should be in what you look for in a
partner it breaks down a lot of your
personality and helps you set up the
path for you to win now it's not an
exact science
right I'm sure I deviate from advocates
who are people in my category on
different things but it gives you a
general benchmark it gives you a general
understanding that gives you some
strategies that at the worst case you
could try on and see does this fit for
you and so I think with all of these
seven steps is about gaining awareness
it's about gaining an understanding to
the things that make you unique putting
things on your radar that then you can
dive into under
stand more deeply and when you figured
those things that when you follow these
seven steps and then bring them to your
business it allows you to win it allows
you to win because you are being you
you're being authentic it's the only way
you're gonna win but now you have a
sense and understanding of what being
you and being authentic actually looks
like so the my seven steps on how to
figure out how you are unique I would
love to know which one of the seven
resonated the most with you and do you
want to add an eight nine ten to the
list let me know put it down in the
comments below
raise your standard Apple epic or its
core value is that passion not one drop
of my self-worth depends on your it's
suppose to mean if you liked this video
check out the one I did on five ways to
find your passion it's right next to me
I think you're gonna enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there you
have to have a lot of passion for what
you're doing because it's so hard that
if you don't any rational person would
give up